so we have sagwoon here one of our one
of our
one of our lovely speakers
and he is an in engine research engineer
with face facebook ai reci research he's
previously worked as an ml developer
the data science team in adobe
systems
his
stack primarily comprises of python and
related ms visualization do
duplicates toolkits and he loves to play
with new technology and look forward to
meeting people at pi data
and uh
if you'd like to
kick off your talk thank you for the
kind introduction um i hope the screen
is visible the slides are visible
i cannot see this uh i cannot see the
chart so i request you to uh you know
still keep posting the questions but uh
i'll be answering the questions uh after
the end of the talk so i'll make sure i
leave about five minutes in the end
for us to go with the questions
uh yeah so so we are going to talk about
profiling and tuning pi touch modules uh
beef intro so i'm a research engineer at
fair i primarily work on lifelong
learning and reinforcement learning and
i have been using and talking about
python for about three years now so
hopefully there would be something
useful for the audience in this talk
um
just a high level introduction to
fighters which probably people don't
need if they are already in the store
by torch is this python package which
provides two high-level features it
provides a tensor computation uh you can
think of tensor as uh nd array that
numpy provides it provides this tensor
abstraction with a strong gpu
acceleration support so you can create
tensors on the gpu you can perform
operations on these tensors on gpu
and the second thing it provides is this
autograd system which makes it very
useful tool for implementing neural
networks or implementing
um
complex machine learning architectures
a quick disclaimer this slide is based
on pytorch 1.9.1 and i'm saying this
because i think about
four or five days back python 1.10 came
out uh that has all the things that i'm
going to describe here and it has
certain extra things uh specifically
related to profiling for example it has
support for photographs uh so those
topics are not covered in this slide
this focuses on pytorch as it was in
1.9.1
okay so with this
let's get started with pytorch profiling
so what's the idea behind profiling the
idea is we have a pie touch model and we
want to profile it or we want to figure
out where the where the model is
spending most of its time
and once we have figured out where the
model is spending its time we can look
at different tips and tricks for for
optimizing the model so so the first
step when we want to accelerate or make
our model go faster or drain faster the
first thing is we have to identify the
bottlenecks and this is what by touch
profiling would cover
uh so the good part is uh when you are
doing python profiling you do not need a
new library because pytorch ships with a
profiler within itself so the library
itself contains a profiler
and
when you are using this uh the profiler
lives within the dodge namespace so you
can just do a from torch import profiler
and you have the profiler with you
throughout the slide there are these
links which which are called as further
reading these are basically links to the
documentation so when you're looking at
the slides later on you have access to
all the links at the at the right place
and these slides would be available
publicly they are already available
publicly i'll share the link
uh in the slab group
so the tldr is the python profiler
pytorch ships with a profiler so you
don't really need an external profiler
which is a good thing one less thing to
install
uh now how do we use this profiler so
what i have here is in the first line
i'm creating a resnet 80 model
uh it's okay if you don't know what a
sn8 model is that's that's not the
relevant part the important thing is i
have a pie touch model
and then i'm just creating a random
input and i'm creating a random input
because i don't really care about the
model's predictions i want to see where
the model is spending most of its time
and once i have the model and the input
i create this context manager with with
the profiler so remember the profiler is
coming from tor so from torch we are
importing the profiler so i create a
context manager where i say hey i want
to profile the cpu activities
and i know i said that you can run
tensors and everything on gpu and the
profiler does support gpu
does support tracking
uh memory and time and other things on
the gpu but for this example we are
tracking only the
activities on the cpu so we are assuming
everything is on the cpu for this
example later we'll see an example where
things are on the coda devices
so we are saying that we want to track
the cpu activity which basically means
we want to track metrics related to cpu
and we also want to record the shapes
record shapes basically means when the
when we pass in an input and different
layers apply different kind of
transformations we want to record the
shape of those transformations
uh sometimes this can be useful for
understanding uh how the network is laid
out but generally turning on record
shapes equal to true it's it's going to
slow down your profiler because now the
profiler has to track more things so if
you if you don't need to record the
shapes you can just uh set it to forms
so we create the we we use this context
manager and then there is this other
function called as
a record underscore function the second
context manager this is really for our
convenience this is more that this is
more from the perspective that once we
would print out the logs we want to have
this thing called as model underscore
inference a high level node in the
profiler which would which would track
everything happening within the model
but you can very well remove this and
the profiler would still be good to go
and the third line is where i'm calling
the model with the input so this is
basically it's it's it's passing the
inputs to the model and since we don't
care about the predictions or the output
we are not tracking that we just call
this
now when we when we call this uh
so so once you have called this
you uh
you have got this context now uh this
context manager uh denoted as prof
and so from the clock you can print out
the the profile
and you could say how many rows you want
to see and you can say what metric do
you care about by what metric do you
want to sort the things so in this case
for example we see that
the
the different
operators that we are looking in the
first column which is the name column
they are sorted by the cpu time total
which basically means how much time was
spent uh performing those operators
the first thing that you will see is
model underscore inference which is
basically the name
the record function name that i was
using
uh if i had not put up the statement the
first line would not be there uh but it
would not change anything else
you see a bunch of other uh function
call other operator costs like eight and
con 2d eight in convolution 18
underscore convolution these are
basically
uh invoking the convolutional kernel and
uh and we have bunch of these
convolutional calls and a bunch of batch
norm calls because the resnet18 model
has a bunch of convolutional and batch
number layers so looking at it it's it's
clear that uh most of the time is being
i mean other than a model influence
which is something at a top level which
you're tracking
most of the time in the setup is being
spent into the convolutional
layers uh
and along with this the the profiler
also gives you the total cpu time or the
total time it took for uh for this
operation to be done
uh
now let's say i i um so yeah so
let's say i optimize something in the
setup and uh obviously we haven't talked
about what we can optimize or what we
cannot optimize but for the moment let's
assume i tell you what you can optimize
in this setup
uh so so you you do that optimization
and the goal here is that we do some
optimization and we read on the profiler
and we make sure whether things have
improved or not so what i'm doing here
is the first two lines are basically the
same as before i'm creating an s918
model i'm setting up some inputs
and then i'm if he uh you know i'm
declaring the decorator the profiler
again
the optimization that i have done is
this line where i'm saying i'm putting
an additional context manager where i'm
saying
uh set it in the influence mode it's
perfectly okay if you don't uh we we
don't have to worry about what inference
mode is doing uh
spoiler alert what it does is it puts
the model in the inference mode so that
gradient tracking and other things are
disabled uh for the
uh
from the perspective of this slide the
important thing is that this is an
optimization which is going to make the
model faster and we want to make sure
that once we run this and we look at the
logs with the other profiles with the
profiler we actually see a speed up so
so you don't need to worry about what
this is doing we are going to cover that
in the next half of the talk
okay so i done the same thing again and
this time the total cpu time is about
460 milliseconds and just to go back a
couple of slides the earlier time was
750 milliseconds so again the important
thing is you you do an optimization
change or you or you do a change which
you think would make the system go
faster so you do not change and you can
run the profiler once again and you can
see that whether this whether this thing
has worked or not
and this is how you should generally be
going about when you're profiling your
models so so profile it before making a
change
make the change generally try to make
only one change at a time so make that
change another profile again and make
sure
things are faster
uh
yeah and this is basically the previous
stack uh sorry it's so i'm basically
showing you the new profile and the
previous profile next to each other the
one on the top is the newer profile the
other on the bottom is the previous
profile
so you can again see what are the places
or what are the operations where we are
spending most of the time
um
yeah
and i think the again we are not going
into the details of how no underscore
inference mode works but in this case
you would see for example that actually
all the operations become somewhat
cheaper
so so the optimization that we did
wasn't for one specific component it was
more of a general optimization
and and doing analysis like this is
useful because sometimes you might do an
optimization which makes one operator go
faster but might make the other operator
go slower and then being able to compare
the profiles next to each other it may
it make sure that you do not make one
piece go fast at the cost of the other
one
now if we were to do the same thing with
uh when the model is running on gpu so
we we have the same setup as before we
we create this model and we create the
inputs and the difference is that after
creating the model we are sending it to
the gpu device so dot code is going to
send it to a gpu
the other difference is that now i am
also tracking along with the cpu
activities i am tracking the cuda
activities or the gpu activities as well
so i have another
entry in the activities list
i again put this model inference
top level name and i i run the model
again i don't care about what the
outputs are we just want to look at the
profile
and this time when i'm printing the
profile i want to look at the cura time
total so instead of looking at the cpu
time total now we want to look at the
kuda time or the time that is spent on
the gpu
uh
yeah so couple of things that stand out
well first of all you have a lot more
columns than what you had earlier which
is because earlier you just had cpu
metrics but now you have coda metrics as
well
the second thing uh
sorry the second thing is now along with
the cpu total time you have the cura
total time as well so it's telling you
how much time was spent on the cpu
device and how much time was spent on
the gpu device
and in this case again i have sorted it
by the cooler time i could have sorted
by the other
the cpu time as spent
you would see again the convolutional
layers are something that comes out you
would see a bunch of operations like sgm
uh
which are
which were probably not there earlier
because these are the kura kernel calls
and
you still have the batch norm and other
operators that we saw earlier
uh this is the same uh this is this is
basically the previous table again with
some of the columns removed out uh so we
see uh
yeah so these are the three new columns
of intervals that have been added which
is a time the kuda time the the
percentage of the time spent and the
actual cuda total time that was spent
and what we see is that in this in this
network most of the time is spent in
this
function called coordinate underscore
convolution which is running the
convolution on the on the gpu
one thing to note is that the self coda
time is not going to add up to one
because uh for example in this case apn
coding convolution is actually invoking
some of these other expensive operations
so if you if you if you hope that these
times would turn up would add up to
uh would add up to 100 that's not the
case that's because one operator is
actually determining the other operators
and this this view is useful because
when you see that the qdn convolution is
an expensive operator you also
understand that it's it's expensive
because of the sgm
underscore sm operator
so it gives you a more fine-grained view
of what exactly you should be focusing
on or optimizing
okay
now so far when we were logging these
things we were only looking at the
time we were not looking at the memory
but we can look at the memory as well
and uh in this example i'm showing how
to track the memory on gpu but you can
do the same thing for cpu as well it's
just that you would not be sending your
model and the input to the quora devices
you just have to pass this additional
flag called as profile memory so just
like we sent this record shapes equal to
true we can send the profile memory
equal to 2 as well
just like record shape incurs an extra
overhead for tracking the shapes profile
memory is also going to incur an extra
overhead
but when you are profiling things that
is going to be okay but when you are
when you are running these things for
training or for inference you probably
do not want to be running the profiler
okay uh so now we have got some
additional columns we have got a bunch
of columns uh related to cpu memory and
a bunch of columns related to decoda
memory as well
uh
yeah now this this view is useful but
this view has its own limitations uh
and there is a even more fine grain view
that you can get which is called as the
which is basically the trace view so you
run your model you generate a trace and
i'll show what it is
means of how a trace looks like but
basically so you you can you can earn
your profiler as before and once you
have finished the profiler you can ask
for a trace
via this export chrome trace function
and you can you can upload this trace on
chrome and visualize that so that's what
we are gonna do uh we wouldn't spend a
lot of time into uh understanding the
entire trees but we look at a few
interesting things that come out
uh so once you have the trace you just
go to chrome
colon slash tracing and you can upload
the trace uh i'm going to come back to
this image in a minute uh this is
basically the zoomed in view of the
trace but i want to show how the trace
looks like when when you are uploading
it
so uh
oops
yeah so i'm uh
i'm on the on the browser on the url and
i'm going to upload our trace uh i have
a few traces generated already
so um okay this is a bit slow
let's probably go okay now this work uh
okay
so i have a trace which i'm gonna upload
now
um
it's gonna take a little while
uh
let me just move this
okay
let me let me close the other two tabs
these are basically the same place open
uh as a backup but since this trace
thing is working we don't need them and
let me move around this cursor a little
bit yes okay so so there's a lot of
things happening here let's let's
minimize the information and look at
some of the interesting pieces
so
uh
yeah for those of you who haven't used
traces before you can
a trace is basically showing you when
which operator is involved
on
on the top you have the times it gives
you at what time what operator was
executed and it also tells you what
further operations were executed by an
operator so let's take an example i'm
just zooming in a bit
so you see for example
and probably this is not very clean to
see so we can go back to the slide
uh
what you see is uh
yeah so for example you see that there
is this uh
a10 con 2d operation which is invoking a
18 convolution operation which is
invoking a 810 underscore convolution
operation and so this gives you a view
of which operation is invoking each
other operation and this view wasn't
very clear from the tables that we had
been looking at so far
uh so this is this is one interesting
aspect another interesting aspect is you
see that there are some sort of white
spaces
between different operations
and this is basically the stall time
this is a time where we are not running
an operation and then that generally
happens because we are waiting for the
devices to synchronize or there is an
operation which you are waiting for
for which we are waiting that it would
finish or there is a kernel call that
has been initiated but hasn't been
started so these these white spaces that
you see these are places for improvement
a last thing i want to show before we
move out is i have this flow event
option and i can turn on async
and you would see a lot of red lines
coming in uh let's just look at it
because it's i think it gives out a
strong uh sort of
a message which is not very obvious so
when you look at this what these lines
are showing is
since
this this trace was generated for a
model that is running on gpu so so what
happens is for example you register an
operation you launch the operation so
you can see uh let me turn on the flow
for now so you see there is a there's an
operation called as cuda launch panel
and when you are doing uh gpu operations
we often say that these things are
asynchronous and what it means is you
launch it
and then you wait for for the gpu to
execute it
and this is what you see in the flow
event so if i now zoom out
uh if i now zoom out you see there is a
there are all these lines which are
starting from these kernel calls and
which are uh oops
let me
move it a little bit
yeah so there are all these lines which
are starting from the
kernel calls and which are uh
yeah which are which are going into
these uh
operations which are involved on the gpu
and you can see an operation for example
that was registered here or invoked here
actually gets executed
way further in the future
uh and this is basically the
asynchronous processing that we talked
about where we say that hey we have we
have launched an operation and the
kernel has been executed and then we'll
get the device back so the so these red
lines these flows that you see this flow
is basically denoted in that behavior
um
okay
and this is a bunch of other things that
you can see for example you can see when
an operation was queued how many times
it was cured and so on uh we wouldn't go
into all the all the aspects but there
are further links if you want to
understand these pieces or look at these
pieces
okay let's get let's get back to the
talk uh
we have about six minutes left
uh okay so yeah so there are a bunch of
other useful things uh if you want to
visualize these profiles as flame graphs
there's there's code for that
how to run profiler when you're
analyzing long running jobs how to use
profiler with tensorboard or vs code
there are there are useful links for all
these things
at this point let's turn gears and let's
go into how can we tune pi touch models
so what we have seen so far is once you
have done something how do you know
whether this is good or bad and now how
do you do these good things to to make
your model go faster
uh some of these tips and tricks are
going to be very general and sort of
useful all the time so you don't
you don't have to
you it doesn't depend on the model
architecture you are using and some of
these are going to be dependent on the
model architecture
so the first example or the first tip is
whenever you're using a data loader use
data enable multi-processing and the way
you enable multi-processing is when
you're creating the data loader you pass
this flag called as num workers and you
pass it to something positive and num
workers is going to allocate that many
uh worker processes for for creating the
data a data loader batch so you are not
bottlenecked on the batch creation step
and if you don't do it by default it's a
single process so it's going to take
longer for your batch to be ready
again
with all the slides we have the further
reading references so you can go into
the documentation and you can see
what are the nitty nitty-gritty details
the second optimization is called as
memory pinning what memory pinning does
is when you are moving data from cpu to
gpu especially when you are using data
loaders uh every time you move the the
data from cpu to gpu you are entering a
cost in memory make sure that this cost
is amortized as reduced because uh it it
basically pin some memory and it's
faster to transfer data from cpu to gpu
when the data resides in the pin memory
uh
it's it's again very easy to enable all
you have to do is when you're updating
the data loader just pass spin memory
equal to true
uh the third example is the inference
mode which we saw earlier and we saw we
were getting a good amount of speed up
with that
what inference mode does is well
influence mode uh it gives you better
performance but the way it gives you
better performance is that it disables
view tracking and version counter what
it basically means is you should be
using inference mode only when you know
that the code that you're gonna use
would not be used with autograd or you
would not be computing gradients on that
and whenever you are using such a code
you can use the inference mode with that
oops
another common sort of
you know generally applicable
optimization is when you're using
optimizer uh we generally do an
optimizer.zerogrand but instead of doing
an optimizer.zerograd you can pass this
extra argument called as setup scholar
set to none
and then the gradients would not be 0
the gradients would be set to none and
just for our large enough models this
can be a performance benefit because you
are not actually
going to the parameters and explicitly
setting them to zeros
it has some caveats and i would
recommend that you you go through the
documentation to understand whether
those caveats would be a problem for you
uh another thing another very sort of uh
useful thing to do is uh enable the kodi
in an auto tuner and for that you just
have to set this uh this this argument
uh to be true
when you start running your code
uh the downside of this is that it can
make your code non-deterministic i mean
that's that's one caveat all the
optimization that we are seeing they
have caveats in some cases they would
care about those caveats in some cases
you would not uh it just it's better to
be aware that there are caveats and
you know instead of being surprised by
by the results
uh so the caveat of kodi kodi an auto
tuner is that it can make your results
non-deterministic
and this is generally specifically for
the convolutional network so if you're
not using contents maybe this is not
relevant for you
uh this is another easy way whenever
you're doing multi gpu processing
instead of using distribu instead of
using data parallel use distributed data
parallel in fact i think at this point
data parallel has been depleted so it's
it's
yeah there's no scenario there's no use
case where you should be using data
parallel instead of distributed data
parallel
uh another example is that you should be
fusing point wise operators and it's a
little tricky one but the high level
idea is
when you're stuck when you're when your
operators
uh on the gpu are sometimes even on cpu
and when you have operations like this
where you are saying x multiplied by
half into sum sum sum so that when you
have a lot of these point wise
operations
pilot torch would be
launching a separate kernel for all of
them and sometimes the overhead of
launching these corners could be too
high and so what you can do is you can
fuse them into one single kernel call
and all you need to do for that is add
this decorator at the right.script
and there are a bunch of other ways of
doing it this is probably one of the
most convenient ones
uh tldr if you have a lot of point wise
operators consider using jit to fuse
them into one single call that would
save you the kernel overhead
building on the idea of using jitting
you can also use fused optimizers this
is a little bit more involved because
depending on your use case you might
have to build the optimizer from the
source and not all the optimizers are
supported at this point
but it gives you the similar benefits as
we saw in the previous slide so you can
use fused optimizers as well
uh this is another advanced optimization
but the idea is that
when you have a very large model and you
have a large batch space you checkpoint
the intermediate buffers which basically
means that instead of carrying around
the entire computation graph you
checkpoint it on the disk so that you
can you have more memory available on
the system and when you are doing a
backward pass uh you you load those
checkpoints so this gives you this frees
up some memory so this this enables you
to use larger models but this would slow
down training so it's an optimization on
the memory side but not an or it's a it
takes a performance hit on the
uh time side
all right shotgun i'm going to
check it start checking to see if
anyone's got questions
yeah i'm so bad i didn't cut you off too
soon oh no it's just two slides left so
we are actually at good time at a good
place
oh all right yeah you go ahead if you
want to
uh okay i'll just quickly cover the two
slides uh you know avoid the unssh cpu
to gpu synchronization and examples of
these synchronizations are print
statements things like dot item dot cpu
uh really often we don't even realize
that this is a synchronization step but
try to avoid it as long as you can
uh
use mixed precision and emp this is also
a bit advanced but the high level idea
is instead of tracking things in float32
you start tracking weights and other
things in fp16 and that frees up some
memory uh yeah that's it and at the end
there are some references
uh
for for you to give more sort of
guidance and uh more hints for
optimizing the setup
i think for the talk it's definitely
interesting to see what's going on in
like optimization
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much
you have a wonderful day bye